Augusta ADA King Countess of Lovelace
was born ADA Byron on December 10th 1815
and is known today simply as Ada
Lovelace she is celebrated as the
world's first computer programmer the
first person to marry the mathematical
computational capabilities of machines
with the poetic potentialities of
symbolic logic this novel combination
was in no small part a function of ADA's
unusual upbringing she was the daughter
of a reserved but mathematically gifted
mother and the only legitimate child of
the great Romantic poet and notorious
playboy Lord Byron but ADA never
actually met her father her parents
separated when she was only five years
old and Lord Byron died and grace when
he was 36 and ADA was 8 her mother
decided to raise Ada all by herself and
made a great effort to eradicate any
trace of her father's ill influence
which meant removing all poetry from the
little girl's life because she believed
that poetry was the root of Lord Byron's
vice so instead she immersed little ada
in math and science from the age of four
and by the time ADA was 12 she had grown
fascinated with mechanical engineering
and at the age of 12 she wrote a book
titled fly ology in which she
illustrated with her very own diagrams
her plan to build a flying apparatus but
even so she felt that the poetic part of
her was being repressed by her mother's
insistence on science and one day she
famously quipped and this is how teenage
girls rebelled in the 1800s she told her
mother that she was going to pursue
poetical science Ada Lovelace struck up
a friendship with the brilliant but
eccentric Charles Babbage who at the
time was working on strange inventions
that one day would have him celebrated
as the father of the computer their
collaboration was an extraordinary union
of software and hardware Lovely's
brought the poetical science and Babbage
the mechanical engineering through the
machine in 1843 she translated a
scientific paper by an Italian military
engineer adding to it seven footnotes
together they measured
two five pages or two and a half times
the length of the original paper in one
of those footnotes Lovelace wrote Wood
has considered the first complete
computer program which made it the
world's first paper in computer science
and made Lovelace the world's first
computer programmer she was 27 years old